tens of millions of Americans are
packing their bags right now this week
to travel for the holiday triple-a
expects fifty point nine million
travelers to hit the roads the rails and
sky for Thanksgiving journeys of at
least 50 miles and it's the most since
2005 air travel they say will see the
biggest increase of 5% about four
million people are expected to fly this
holiday season this holiday weekend the
busy travel week comes after CBS News
learned security screeners missed
prohibited items at at least 70 percent
of the time at airport checkpoints
during under coming undercover testing
the new TSA administrator David pukowski
is with us now from Washington to
discuss as we get ready to hit the roads
hello David thank you very much for
joining us this morning good morning
think without for the opportunity to be
with you this morning well here's a
question I wonder how is it that they
can get my contact lens solution but
they can't get the weapons and really
prohibited scary items what can you say
to reassure us that things are going to
be better when we travel this weekend
just the other day my contact lens
solution was confiscated David and I had
to throw it out well what we do is
whenever we have a covert test like the
Inspector General conducted and we do
our own testing as well we use that to
test our system and to see where there
are vulnerabilities what we're doing
right now and we've been doing over the
past several weeks in fact into the
summer is additional training for our
transportation security officer work
force who I think does an excellent job
overall looking at changing our
procedures which travelers will see over
the course of this holiday season and
also investigating new technologies that
we can put in place in the checkpoint I
would say to you that I travel often
I think air travel is is safe and secure
and and I think it's actually safer in
secure today after the IG results than
it was beforehand so what specific
things is the TSA doing to improve what
we're doing to improve is first off
we're focusing further on training our
workforce it's a very important part of
our overall security posture I
personally have participated in some of
the training for our transportation
security officers and it's excellent I
and we basically explain to them the why
of what they're doing based on the
intelligence information the threat
information
that we have additionally we've changed
some procedures right now with when you
go to the airport most airports you'll
have to take out of your carry-on bags
any electronic device that's bigger than
a cell phone and put that into a bin and
what that does that procedure allows our
x-ray examiners to have a clearer image
when your carry-on bag goes through the
x-ray machine additionally we have new
lanes in many airports thanks to the
airports and the Airlines partnership
with us and these new lanes allow five
people at the same time to put their
carry-on bags into bins which should
eventually speed up the process and also
provide some security enhancements for
us on the security side of those lanes
and so with those things in particular I
think you'll see an immediate
improvement in security additionally
we're focused very hard and I have
accelerated significantly our
investigation of new technology in the
checkpoints you know al Qaeda has
recently called on attacks on trains in
this country what security precautions
do you have in place for that because
right now it appears that anybody can
just get on a train carrying anything
i we work very closely with with the
with the rail industry in fact I was
just up in New York a couple of weeks
ago went to the New York transit system
and also on Amtrak in New Jersey Transit
we provide guidelines as TSA we don't
actually provide the security unlike at
the airports where TSA provides security
but we provide guidelines to Surface
Transportation owners and operators and
we work very closely with them to assure
intelligence information and also to
share best practices back and forth
between us you'll see as you travel on
surface transportation systems over this
weekend an increased presence of of law
enforcement of k-9 teams and that's part
of the enhanced security posture in
those systems
well David Bukowski thank you so much
for joining us this morning thanks to
all the TSA workers I find them to be
very professional I agree with what are
you saying for the most part they do a
very good job
are you traveling David are you going to
test out your own system I just returned
from travel I'm not traveling my family
is traveling to me but thanks for the
comments on the TSO workforce I do think
they do an outstanding job and it
for coal shopping yes you're absolutely
right about that you know we're going to
be traveling right we're going to be
doing our planes trains and automobiles
as well